should a writer seek out a manager or
should they wait till the manager seeks
them out I think that like they should
seek out a manager for sure but I do
think that there's
effective ways to do that
for instance seeing in the roster is
there somebody that you have a personal
relationship to so you could go through
you know ideally like a friend who may
be wrapped by a manager that could be
helpful
sorry so you said a roster like so a
manager might have a you know like
multiple clients that are that they work
with you know and one of them might be
the friend of a writer who's unwrapped
and then they just like might just go to
somebody in that you know who that
manager reps and a writer or whoever and
then just say hey you know I love to get
my work to your manager could you make
an introduction
so that's a way to do it
um another way to do it
is you basically
just go you know go through like just an
email you have an email Quarry you know
letter where you just send it and I
think that they just need to be really
simple like hey my name is such and such
I have a science fiction script
um I would love for you to check it out
here's the log line
if you're interested I'm happy to sign
like a script release just uh no one
just wants to get exposed a bunch of
material legally so just saying hey I'm
open to sign that you know keep it
simple
that's great like that's all you know
that's a very simple email and ideally
you research the managers because like I
don't really work with a lot of like you
know like purely comedy clients like
it's just not my
you know it's on my wheelhouse and you
know sometimes people just will be like
you're a manager but they don't see that
of a specific curation
so I think you really need to know who
you're contacting or else you're wasting
your time
and I think that like there doesn't need
to be a whole narrative to that email it
needs to be something that you could
just
pick up your iPhone and just read it and
go okay do I like this log line does
that interest me
you know because sometimes I get these
emails are super long
and I don't have a lot of bandwidth you
know so for me it's just like it's
almost like diminishing returns
on making it too wordy it's almost
better just to say
my concept is so hot like you're going
to want to read the script it's going to
be you're just going to read it and
you're like tell me more
and that's enough but you know sometimes
you get too much information and you
know I think that it's not the the right
uh way to move forward because it's just
as confusing because you're like what
did this person want who are the it just
becomes more about it if it's like
here's an idea
let's talk you know and I think that's
the the key to do is just keep it simple
what is a script release
like some type of like you know
paperwork that you know they signed that
so you know
you're not
you know connected to their script if
you somehow 10 years later have a you
know slightly similar project or it's
just like it's it's customary for almost
all managers
you know to have some level of
protection for being exposed to new work
so it releases you of liability in case
they feel that there's another script
out there similar to their I guess I
mean it's just normal I mean whatever
you know any way to frame it I mean it's
just no one wants to like get a bunch of
scripts sent to them and then somehow is
your connection to other materials just
keeps it simple it's just a professional
way
um when you're exposed to new work and
you know just smart for any manager to
not just get random you know emails or
scripts so you know you know someone's
not really familiar with the businesses
if they start by emailing you their
script they should always like be
clearly open to like signing that
release
at what point should a writer
reevaluate whether they're ready to
approach a manager or an agent I don't
you know I think that like ideally they
have like a body of work that
you know speaks to their voice so let's
say they you know write in the romantic
comedy genre if they have a few scripts
that really are like reflective of who
they are then why not you know I think
um they shouldn't
try out you know the different you know
steps to getting a rep I think it's
valuable now if someone's not really
clear on what they want to do
and they're still kind of discovering
what gets them excited and maybe they
should just kind of like have fun and
make things and then kind of find their
their voice later and there's no
pressure to have a rep you don't need
one as you know as a Creator you could
just do your own thing but I think it
it's it's valuable when you have a sense
of
what kind of you know
um you know Creator you want to be what
genre you want to work in who do you
want to collaborate with so the more
specific you get about what you're
passionate about is probably the time
where maybe a rep could be valuable
how common is it for a manager to part
ways with their client I mean I think
it's like Case by case I don't think
there's like a frequency or a normal way
to do it or you know where it's like
more or less given you know like the
manager like there's not like
I guess a way like a framework where you
could point to like this is what's
typical
but you know I just think that in
general like
you know people who are working together
on a regular basis
should have like you know they can't
always have a shared Vision that's not I
mean nobody you work with in any
profession is always completely aligned
but I think that it has to be in the in
a certain like level communication
or there's a mutual respect and the
paths that you've embarked on
are um accepted and ex and they excite
you you and your collaborator versus a
huge Schism in the sense of you know
strategy so yeah I mean it's just case
to case you know I think you just have
to work with people
that gets you excited and get you
passionate so I think that's the most
important part and whether or not
there's a departure or they're not I
mean that's fine you know you really
have One Life to Live you want to enjoy
who you work with
sure because there can be people that
are they're brilliant in what they do
and then maybe temperament wise they're
not a match or vice versa there could be
people that as you said earlier you want
to hang with but maybe Talent level
they're not there yet yet you know I
think that like
you just want to work with people
that you believe in you know and and
they have to believe in you too so there
that's a collab you know it's the
collaboration
and you know that
there's uh you know there's going to be
challenges you know in all facets of the
business but you're fine with them you
know like I said it's all about
adaptation so can you work together as
everything shifts and you have to keep
coming up with new ways to find the win
because that's what we want to do we
want to
push to go forward you want to keep
moving we want to keep progressing and I
think that's the goal is that the people
you're working with
have that you know the same vision
to lead to being a successful
filmmaker you know and I think that like
same with you as a manager you share the
success with your clients you know
something you feel the winds too
so I think that the question is
do your client and you
have a have that partnership that's
meaningful and if there is problems and
either of the person doesn't want to
work together that's fine you know they
could work with somebody else or vice
versa it's not a tragedy it's just you
have to work with people
that you find it a fulfilling profession
to be part of this team and that's what
that's what matters is that at the end
of the day you didn't just sell the
project you know and you feel good you
like that you like what the person's
about you like what you you really enjoy
the the getting there it's not just that
one sale it's like
the the communication was in place you
know you guys like you get excited about
the same movies you know so I think that
you know it's fine if relationships part
because then maybe there's a another rep
who connects with them in a better way
so it's not about just collecting random
people it's about building successful
teams
and it's great to have belief in people
but unfortunately in the real world
people will let you down and maybe they
don't try to maybe it's not intentional
but have you ever had to have a
conversation with someone that says you
know I need you to be more on point or
we had this meeting and you didn't show
up you don't have to give me specifics
as to who someone is but where they
weren't holding up there into the
bargain
and you had to have quote The Talk
honestly no like I don't want to have
that talk I mean I think that you know
there is a period where you're talking
to a potential client and you just have
to be honest like with them about how
you like to work and you know maybe you
talk to their collaborators about their
experience working with them and just
get a sense of like what's important you
know and
when you know what's important
to a collaborator and they know your
values I don't have issues about
performance so it's not like somebody is
like slipping is that we've already kind
of got through it in the initial like
introduction and uh and you know teaming
up
okay what if someone has some dry
periods in their life where they're not
creating anything
would you retain them as a client I mean
like everybody has to
work their own way like there isn't like
it's not a mechanical process it's not
like they're making widgets you know is
that it's deeply personal to tell a
story you know it's not something that
you could just you know turn into a
system where you could just do a paint
by numbers process and if you could it'd
probably be a terrible movie
um
if that's not what I want they might
have to take time you know so
when there's a collaborator and they're
like hey I need some distance to kind of
come up with an idea or you know the
work on a project
that's fine I have plenty of clients
that are in the mix of something new so
the only area where that could be
problematic and I haven't dealt with
that personally but if somebody is hired
to do a job
and then they can't execute on it that's
where that becomes a problem not when
they need time to you know write a new
spec it's when there's a contract sign
and you know money has exchanged hands
and somebody's like paralyzed that could
be
an issue for sure like but it's not a to
me it's not a big deal if
a Storyteller needs to sit back and like
watch movies like live a little bit run
around do different things and then just
lock in
to
a vision for a project like uh my
brother's a filmmaker and I see him
sometimes like he'll have to walk into a
museum or he'll do something or he'll go
somewhere and then he'll get his mind
activated so I've seen it growing up and
my dad is also an author he's written
some historical uh you know novels he
needs to just kind of like get that
Groove so it's fine to me I don't have
an expectation that a person has to
constantly be churning out material
uh they whatever they need to get you
know the ideas you know
building you know and moving forward is
fine with me
as an advance on a book and
they have a contractual obligation to
turn in some type of pages at a certain
time and they haven't
you've never had to deal with no and
then you're calling and there's no
return calls and you know you never had
to
face that no like the when the when the
contract is signed I've had clients just
get to work you know it's not precious
at all they just do their job and I know
sometimes like
you'll see um
you know movies this like you know
author who's like you know totally out
to lunch and not in the game at all and
then their agents calling or whatever
you know but like for Pages no I haven't
dealt with that they're you know they're
working on a project or professionals
and they're delivering uh you know on
time okay so you haven't had any scenes
of like factotum or bar fly where you
have to go and
pull someone out of the corner bar and
get them in front of the typewriter no
not at all like uh it's not that you
know unfortunate it's not that exotic
it's not like a movie it's just kind of
like this do their thing like if you're
hiring somebody in any profession good
okay sounds like you have a good
intuition as to who you take on so yeah
definitely